you and your team have engaged in this
awesome act of like citizen diplomacy
and fixing some of the problems caused
by the governments now what advice would
you give to people who want to do some
citizen diplomacy of their own but you
know don't have their own TV show well
first of all I think in but we're about
six years away from everybody having
their own TV show so there's so many
problems that can be solved first of all
by getting down to the granular level
and meeting people and in the short time
I was there like I want to get involved
with the school because I went there and
I met the teachers and I played with the
kids and it was a joyous experience so
now I have a connection and I feel
involved with them that's something
anybody can do and I think sometimes
we're overwhelmed we get empathy fatigue
I understand I understand why people in
the United States want to turn their
back on other people because they get
overloaded they feel threatened they
feel like who's gonna look after me I'm
tired of this can't we just close the
borders can't we just it is a I don't
agree with it but I understand where
it's coming from I just think when you
go to these places these people that can
have these that can dismiss entire
swaths of the globe you go to these
places and you get involved with the
people you see on a small level you know
what I like this school or I'd like to
help this village or I would like to
help this institution right here and if
nothing else be a good representative of
the United States I think that's huge
because you go there and I think just in
our short trip we caught some of it on
film but we just tried to show that
we're not here to take anything we're
here to help and you guys can laugh at
me I'm not here to make fun of you
you're here to make fun of me and laugh
at my efforts to try and assimilate into
your culture so I think anybody can do
that
I really do I don't think you need a TV
show to do it
you